[Funny Music]
Voice of a Man: When it comes to reaping profits from your app,
You have to pay attention to quality.
High-quality application will receive a better evaluation,
Leading to more downloads,
And then more profits.
Here are ten tips for successful developers
When the application is ready.
The app developer unit can automatically convert your app's price
To local currencies around the world.
However, conversion rates do not reflect local expectations
Purchasing power,
So look for local economic conditions and research
Good looking interests.
If you see that the price of your app will be frustrating for users,
But you see that they will see a value worth the price after using it,
Download and try it for free.
After a certain time, you can view your purchase on them once
So they can use it forever.
Applying the application for free helps overcome any obstacles
Resulting from the price,
You can also view additional features for users at a certain price
After attracting their attention towards the application.
Create a free application with basic features
So that the user will interact with it
Then showcase advanced features with in-app purchases
Such as ad removal,
Or add an enhanced function,
Or add items within the game.
Instead of selling digital goods within applications,
Especially when there are recurrent costs of content,
You can sell content and features through a subscription.
You can view the free trial experience for users to familiarize them with the app,
Followed by a recurring subscription
On a variety of time periods,
Whether weekly, monthly or annually.
If you offer to subscribe to the app,
It may add additional content or features to your site
Users have value to subscribe
And makes it more attractive.
Sign users in to your website
Check out the details of their participation in Google Play
To enable features or content on the web.
Google Analytics helps provide useful information
About the behavior of users in your app.
You can use the flow of behavior
To understand how users navigate within the app
And the content they are alienating from.
E-commerce applications can take advantage of this information in
Improve purchase flow,
Game developers also know which levels are more difficult
And when assistance should be provided to players.
You can take advantage of this information to improve your app experience,
With increased conversions for installation to users who pay.
Users can explore an application in several ways
Now you can search for the selected source
Which is more effective.
It shows you a User Acquisition Performance report in the Developer Console
Number of users visiting the store listing,
The number of choose to install the application,
And the number of being purchases.
You'll know where the most important users come from
And then you know the place that needs concentration and effort.
The most experienced users of your apps
More important than what you can target with other offers.
If you're earning from AdMob ad serving
In your apps,
You can take advantage of the house ads feature,
Which allows you to participate in the ad inventory
And use it to co-promote your own apps and games.
Users who have already purchased in-app products
A good targeting opportunity for future purchases,
So tell them what you want to show.
You can do this with the same free company ads on AdMob.
Create in-app house ads
AdMob will automatically calculate the number of users
Who are expected to pay
And then show them these ads.
AdMob will continue to show regular ads to other users.
Retaining existing users can help
Effective use of marketing funds.
With AdWords engagement campaigns,
Connect with users who have already installed your app
They have not used it recently,
Or active users who have not yet fully explored it.
When users search on Google, they'll be shown
AdWords serves your ads
So you can remind them of key features
Or offer them special offers.
By indexing applications,
You can link users to a specific page in your app
Related to them.
If you want to get more tips,
On how to increase your app or game earnings
Create a better business for apps,
You can download the "Secrets of app success on Google Play" guide.